[Applause]
what up Joe Joe how you
doing great great how about
you good luck good luck match up match
up match up there you go
yni get out get
out yeah yeah yes oh no come on face SC
face SC face
SC my bad I was I was going to shoot it
when you found me when you found me
first I I was going throw it up I was
about to shoot it right when I got I was
going to shoot it when I got
hit help get you back on balance I'm
with you I'm with you keep going green
keep going be ready it's a
weak be ready
bees strong strong strong great idea
great look great idea we'll get that for
two he be ready be ready be ready I got
to talk to you I was there for you I got
to talk to you